AMAZON.
THE SHARE CLOSED HIGHER TODAY,
UP 17%.
>> Bret: OKAY, DEIRDRE,
THANK YOU.
MORE ON WITH US THE PANEL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SEEMS TO HAVE
THE BACK OF AND EMBATTLED
ENVIRONMENTAL AGENCY CHIEF
SCOTT PRUITT.
PRESIDENT GAVE HIM A PET TOP
DURING A PHONE CONVERSATION
YESTERDAY, SOURCES TELL US,
THERE ARE STILL CONCERNS ABOUT
RECENT NEGATIVE HEADLINES.
IN OTHER WORDS, THAT DOES NOT
MEAN PRUITT WILL ESCAPE THE
GROWING SCRUTINY OVER SOME
QUESTIONABLE.
>> SCOTT PRUITT, SIR.
>> I HOPE HE IS GOING TO BE
GREAT.
>> A TEMPERATE ENDORSEMENT IN
THE FUTURE TRANSFER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S BESIEGED EPA
ADMINISTRATOR SCOTT PRUITT AS HE
FACES SEVERAL NEW ACCUSATIONS.
TODAY TWO DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN
ROAD EPA'S INSPECTOR GENERAL
REQUESTING AN INVESTIGATION INTO
HIS REPORTED SWEETHEART DEAL ON
THIS CAPITOL HILL CONDO OWNED BY
ENERGY LOBBYISTS.
THEIR LETTER SAYS, "EPA APPROVED
THE PIPELINE EXPANSION PLAN OF A
CANADIAN ENERGY COMPANY WHO
APPOINTED HIM AS A LOBBYIST.
AT THE SAME TIME, MR. PRUITT WAS
LEASING THE CONDO AT A BELOW
MARKET RATE."
EP ETHICS OPINION NORTH AND
AFTER THE RENTALS FOUND HIS
CURRENTLY MONT WAS A REASONABLE
RATE.
QUESTIONS REMAIN WHETHER HE PAID
ONLY FOR THE NIGHT THAT HE
STAYED IN THE CONDO IN AN
APPARENT AIRBNB STYLE
ARRANGEMENT.
ALL THIS AFTER HE FACED SCRUTINY
FOR OTHER ALLEGED MISDEEDS.
HIS PATTERN OF FIRST CLASS AIR
TRAVEL, ALLEGEDLY SECURITY, IT
WAS REJECTED BECAUSE OF ITS
$100,000 MONTHLY COST.
PUBLISHED REPORTS ALSO FOUND HIS
ROUND HIS ROUND-THE-CLOCK
PERSONAL SECURITY DETAIL
REQUIRED TRIPLE THE STAFFING OF
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATORS.
LAST SEPTEMBER,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" FROM THE
EPA WAS SPENDING NEARLY
$25,000 TO BUILD A SECURE
SOUNDPROOF BOOTH IN PRUITT'S
OFFICE.
EVEN SOME REPUBLICANS ARE
JOINING THE DUMP PRUITT SCORES.
REPRESENTATIVE CARLOS CURBELO
TWEETED THAT EPA ADMINISTRATOR
SHOULD RESIGN OR PRESIDENT TRUMP
SHOULD DISMISS THEM.
>> RIGHT NOW, PRUITT IS A MARKED
MAN IN WASHINGTON.
>> HIS SUPPORTERS SAY THE
BARRAGES OF TAX IS A TESTAMENT
TO HIS EFFECTIVENESS.
>> SCOTT PRUITT HAS BEEN A
LIGHTNING ROD.
HE HAS BEEN THE INCARNATION OF
AND CLIMATE ACTIVISTS.
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO GO AFTER HIM.
>> PRUITT IGNORED SHOUTING
QUESTIONS AT A CEREMONY TODAY
MARKING HIS LATEST UPFRONT TO
INVENT A ENVIRONMENTALISTS BACK
PRESIDENT TRUMP OBAMA'S --
255.4 MILES PER GALLON BY THE YA
255.4 MILES PER GALLON BY THE YR
2025.
THE STANDARDS REMAIN IN EFFECT,
MASSIVE CHANGES WOULD HAVE HAD
CAR MANUFACTURING IN A VEHICLE'S
MOTORISTS BUY BRACE BECAUSE
STATUTORILY KILLED THE AMERICAN
SUV AS WE KNOW IT.
>> A FEDERAL LAWSUIT WILL LIKELY
FEDERAL-STATE DISPUTE.
IT COULD TAKE YEARS AND LEAVE
AUTOMAKERS IN LIMBO.
WHAT AUTOMOBILE MANUFACTURERS
MOST WANT OF ANY NEW FUEL
ECONOMY STANDARDS IS CONSISTENCY
AND PREDICTABILITY.
SO THEY CAN MAKE LONG-TERM